A quick warning. This episode contains references to adult language and might not be suitable for younger listeners. I think you'll know within about 15 seconds if this episode is appropriate for your kid, so it's just a heads up. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Before Chris Rubey became a big shot 99 PI producer, he had a college radio show in Toronto where he interviewed bands coming through town. I remember this one time when I got the call to sit down with Monster Metal Legends War. You probably know War, they dress like aliens, they're very loud, they're not my thing,
一个温馨提示。本期节目包含成人用语，可能不适合较年轻的听众。我想你在大约15秒内就能判断这期节目是否适合你的孩子，所以这只是个提醒。这里是《无形之物》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。在克里斯·鲁贝（Chris Berube）成为《无形之物》的大牌制作人之前，他在多伦多主持过一个大学广播节目，采访过路过该镇的乐队。我记得有一次，我接到电话去采访怪兽金属传奇乐队——Gwar（莽荒乐队）。你可能知道Gwar，他们打扮得像外星人，声音非常吵闹，这不是我的菜，
but they're fun. So I go into the interview. I'm not in it. So I go into the interview, my tape recorder in hand, and the dudes in Guar cannot stop swearing, even though I repeatedly asked them to stop. The tape of this interview has been lost to history, but it sounded something like this. Hey, Guar, how's it? Oh, uh, please stop the okay. Look, it was not my finest moment as a journalist. The interview went out on the air
但他们很有趣。于是我开始采访。我不在状态。于是我拿着录音机开始采访，Gwar的那些家伙脏话连篇，根本停不下来，尽管我一再请求他们住口。这次采访的录音已经失传了，但听起来大概是这样的。嘿，Gwar，最近怎么样？哦，呃，请停下，好吧。听着，作为记者，这可不是我最的高光时刻。这段采访播出了，
and right after Chris was called into the station manager's office and he was told in no uncertain terms, the interview had too many swear words. But it didn't have swearing. It just had bleeps. But people were concerned about the swearing because to lots of people there isn't much of a difference. The f*** sound is synonymous with bad words. Today the one killer hurts tone is universally understood to be covering up inappropriate words on radio and TV. Don't try to play that.
紧接着，克里斯就被叫进了台长的办公室，并被明确告知，采访中的脏话太多了。但其实里面并没有脏话。里面只有“哔”的消音声。但人们还是对脏话感到担忧，因为对许多人来说，这两者没什么区别。“f***”这个声音就是粗俗脏话的代名词。如今，“哔”这个单音节蜂鸣声在广播和电视上被普遍理解为掩盖不当用语。别想放那个。
I didn't know. You probably hear the bleep button all the time on reality shows like The Bachelor. I knew I didn't. Tammy. Or mockumentary style comedies. I was born ready. I'm proud of this once. Oh, and of course on the PBS Children's Television Show Arthur.
我不知道。你可能在《单身汉》这样的真人秀节目中经常听到“哔”音按钮。我知道我没有。塔米。或者伪纪录片风格的喜剧。我随时准备好了。我为这个时刻感到自豪。哦，当然还有PBS（美国公共电视台）儿童节目《亚瑟》（Arthur）。
You can forget about going to that concert tonight. What? You can't do that! I can't, and I have! Like the member list of Grammy-nominated thrash metal band war, the approach to censoring content on public airwaves is constantly evolving. Right now, the bleep is often used to censor bad words, especially on TV. But there are other options like silence, just making it seem like the swear never happened.
今晚的那场音乐会，你想都别想。什么？你不能这么做！我不能，但我偏要！就像获得格莱美提名的鞭笞金属乐队Gwar的成员名单一样，公众电波中审查内容的手段也在不断演变。目前，“哔”音经常用于审查脏话，尤其是在电视上。但还有其他选择，比如静音，就像脏话从来没发生过一样。
So how did we end up with the bleep? You know, it's actually a pretty interesting story. In the 1920s in America, radio was the hot new thing. After years of newspapers and the telegraph, now even the smallest local radio station could broadcast voices into hundreds or even thousands of homes. You know, they had absolutely no idea what they were doing. Maria Bistios is a writer and editor at Popular. You know, the early days of the internet where people were having blo- people would read
那么，我们是怎么发明出“哔”音的呢？你知道，这其实是一个相当有趣的故事。20世纪20年代的美国，广播是炙手可热的新鲜事物。经历了多年的报纸和电报之后，现在哪怕是最小的地方广播电台，也能将声音广播到成百上千个家庭中。你知道，他们完全不知道自己在干什么。玛丽亚·布斯蒂略斯（Maria Bustillos）是《Popular》杂志的作家和编辑。你知道，就像互联网的早期，人们在写博客——人们会阅读
any blog. They would read anything. It was like, my day at the dry cleaner, you know, and people who, oh my god, this is fascinating. Maria says 100 years ago, there weren't big national broadcasters, and local stations had to figure out how to fill all that time. So they would put pretty much anything on the air. If you had a song you wanted to play or an essay you wanted to read, you could probably just walk into your local radio station and you had a fairly good shot of getting on the air.
任何博客。他们什么都读。就像是，“我在干洗店的一天”，你知道，人们会觉得，哦天哪，这太迷人了。玛丽亚说，100年前，并没有大型的国家广播公司，地方电台必须想方设法填满所有的时间。所以他们基本上什么内容都会播。如果你有一首歌想放，或者有一篇文章想读，你大概可以直接走进当地的广播电台，而且很有希望被播出。
Of course, this creates a ton of opportunities for things to go wrong. Maria points to this one notorious incident from 1921, when a performer named Olga Petrova went on the radio and read an innocent seeming nursery rhyme which was secretly politically incendiary. Olga Petrova was his famous Fodville actress and she went on this radio showing Newark. Olga Petrova wasn't Justin Entertainer, she was also an advocate for birth control. Petrova was close friends with Margaret Sanger who founded the American Birth Control League. Before the radio people could do anything, she started reading her poem. She read this nursery rhyme that was like, there was an old woman who lived in a shoe,
当然，这为各种状况的发生提供了极好的机会。玛丽亚提到了1921年的一起轰动一时的事件，当时一位名叫奥尔加·彼得罗娃（Olga Petrova）的表演者在广播中朗读了一首看似无害、实则暗藏政治煽动性的童谣。奥尔加·彼得罗娃是一位著名的杂耍女演员，她在纽瓦克参加了这个广播节目。奥尔加·彼得罗娃不仅仅是一位艺人，她还是生育控制的倡导者。彼得罗娃与创立了美国生育控制联盟（American Birth Control League）的玛格丽特·桑格（Margaret Sanger）是密友。还没等广播人员反应过来，她就开始朗读她的诗。她读了一首这样的童谣：有一个老太婆，住在鞋子里，
she had so many children because she didn't know what to do. It's kind of a blink and you missed it thing. What to do in the rhyme was birth control. I know it sounds incredibly tame in 2022, but a hundred years ago, Olga Petrova's satirical nursery rhyme was probably against the law. That was terrifying to people.
她有好多好多的孩子，因为她不知道该怎么办。这是一个眨眼就会错过的细节。童谣里的“怎么办”指的就是生育控制。我知道在2022年听起来温和得难以置信，但在一百年前，奥尔加·彼得罗娃这首讽刺性的童谣可能触犯了法律。这让人们感到恐慌。
The 1873 comm stock laws at that point, which had banned the distribution of so-called obscene materials, including information about contraception, which was deemed obscene, were enforced. So the people who ran the radio station are like, oh my god, they're going to take our license. They got her off the air and lucky for the station, the authorities didn't notice. But the men working the board were freaked out, and with good reason, at that point it wasn't clear what content was allowed and what could get your license revoked.
当时1873年的《康斯托克法案》（Comstock laws）仍在执行，该法案禁止分发所谓的淫秽材料，包括被视为淫秽的避孕信息。所以运营广播电台的人吓坏了，天哪，他们会吊销我们的执照的。他们把她赶出了节目，幸运的是，当局没有注意到这个电台。但负责控制台的人吓坏了，而且并非杞人忧天，当时还不清楚哪些内容是被允许的，哪些内容会导致执照被吊销。
After incidents like the one with Petrova, radio operators realized they needed to have a backup, in case somebody like a feminist or worse, a communist got on the air. And that's why they invented bleeping, or sort of bleeping. The original bleep began as a music that cut in, suddenly, to a broadcast that might be sort of problematic. They had another operator the entire time playing classical music. And if anything came up that they didn't want to hear,
在经历了像彼得罗娃那样的事件后，广播运营商意识到他们需要一个备用方案，以防像女权主义者或者更糟糕的共产党人这样的人上了节目。这就是他们发明消音“哔”音的原因——或者说类似“哔”音的东西。最初的“哔”音是一段音乐，会突然切入到那些可能存在问题的广播中。他们全程安排了另一位操作员播放古典音乐。如果出现任何他们不想听到的内容，
there would be a signal to this engineer and like, boom. And you'd be hearing classical music that second. That was like the original version of bleeping. The classical music solution was widely adopted by radio stations across the United States shortly after the Petrova incident. In fact, Olga Petrova ran into the censorship regime in 1924 when she read from one of her plays on a different station. This time, when she hit the potentially offensive material, it didn't get on air.
就会向这位工程师发出信号，然后——轰。你一秒钟内就会听到古典音乐。那就像是消音“哔”音的最初版本。在彼得罗娃事件发生后不久，古典音乐的解决方案被美国各地的广播电台广泛采用。事实上，奥尔加·彼得罗娃在1924年再次遇到了审查制度，当时她在另一个电台上朗读她的一部戏剧。这一次，当她触及潜在的敏感内容时，并没有被播出。
There was an old woman who lived in a shoe she had so many children cut. She had so many children. By the 1950s radio had gone fully professional with big national broadcasters reaching everyone in America It was joined by a dynamic upstart flash in the pan invention called Television heard of it By this point radio and TV were regulated by the Federal Communications Commission, who had the power to dish out fines and even revoke licenses for any content they found in decent, and it was into this brave new world that the bleep button was born. The first bleep was created so radio stations could cover up square words just in the neck
有一个老太婆，住在鞋子里，她有好多好多的孩子——切断。她有好多好多的孩子。到了20世纪50年代，广播已经完全走向专业化，大型全国广播公司覆盖了全美每个人。与之相伴的是一项充满活力、异军突起、昙花一现的发明，叫做电视——听说过吗？到这个时候，广播和电视已经受到联邦通信委员会（FCC）的监管，他们有权对任何他们认为是不正经的内容开出罚单，甚至吊销执照。正是在这个勇敢的新世界里，“哔”音按钮诞生了。第一个“哔”音的创造是为了让广播电台能够及时掩盖脏话。
of time. Most live radio isn't actually live. It's sent to the airwaves seven seconds after it happens in real life. This gives broadcasters seven seconds to catch a swear word and cover it up with a bleep sound before it reaches your ears. You've got a producer with his finger on the button and the button disconnects the broadcast audio and goes, I could probably do that better if I were gone. I don't need to. That's Richard Factor.
大多数直播广播其实并不是真正的直播。它们是在现实生活中发生七秒钟后才通过电波发送出去的。这给了广播公司七秒钟的时间来捕捉脏话，并在它到达你的耳朵之前用“哔”的声音将其掩盖。你有一个制作人，手指按在按钮上，这个按钮会断开广播音频，然后说：如果我走了，我可能会做得更好。我不需要。那是理查德·法克特（Richard Factor）。
He was a board operator at WABC in New York in the 1960s. Back in the days, like the biggest radio station in the country, possibly in the world. Richard says the reason the was an obvious choice is because radio stations use something called an oscillator. An oscillator is built into most mixing boards and it sends out test tones like 100 hertz or 500 hertz or the 1 kilohertz tone. It creates a tone is like a synthesizer.
他是20世纪60年代纽约WABC电台的控台操作员。回想当年，那是国内最大的广播电台，可能也是全世界最大的。理查德说，“哔”音之所以成为显而易见的选择，是因为广播电台使用了一种叫做振荡器的东西。振荡器内置于大多数调音台中，它能发出测试音，比如100赫兹、500赫兹或1千赫兹的音调。它产生的音调就像合成器一样。
If you have a synthesizer, it's nothing but an audio oscillator that they filter and make different tones out of them. Since the oscillator was already built in, Richard says using the bleep tone to cover up a swear word, well, it just made sense. There's nothing special about it. It just covered up the anointy audio because the alternative was just a long stretch of nothing. And silence on the radio is a total no-go. We have to have something because if you go off the air for seven seconds, somebody tunes in and out of the station. While the bleep tone was kicking around in the 50s,
如果你有一个合成器，它其实就是一个音频振荡器，通过滤波产生不同的音调。既然振荡器已经是现成的，理查德说，用“哔”音来掩盖脏话，嗯，这简直顺理成章。这没什么特别的。它只是掩盖了那些令人讨厌的音频，因为唯一的选择就是长长的一片空白。而在广播中，空白是绝对不行的。我们必须得有点声音，因为如果你断播七秒钟，听众就会把电台调走。虽然“哔”音在50年代就已经存在，
it became ubiquitous much later, thanks in part to a fateful Supreme Court case. In 1973, the radio station WBAI decided to test the waters and see if America was ready for uncensored content. They aired a long clip from a comedy routine by George Carlin called The Seven Words You Could Never Say on Television. For those one-drain, the words are... Sh- Sh- Sh-
但它在很久之后才变得无处不在，这在很大程度上要归功于最高法院的一起命运攸关的案件。1973年，WBAI广播电台决定试水，看看美国是否准备好接受未经审查的内容。他们播出了乔治·卡林（George Carlin）的一段喜剧节目的长片段，名为《你永远不能在电视上说的七个词》。对于那些不懂的人，这些词是……Sh- Sh- Sh-
Sh- Sh- Sh- And of course... Sh- Sh- The routine was uncensored and it had a ton of curse words, so the FCC sent a warning to the station's parent company, Pacifica. The whole thing became a first amendment case at the Supreme Court, and the court ruled that actually, no, you cannot err all those swear words.
Sh- Sh- Sh- 还有当然……Sh- Sh- 这段节目未经审查，里面有大量的脏话，于是FCC向该电台的母公司太平洋基金会（Pacifica）发出了警告。整件事情演变成了最高法院的一起宪法第一修正案案件，法院裁定，事实上，不，你不能播出所有这些脏话。
And yeah, the FCC did have the right to decide what was and was not appropriate for the airwaves. The ruling emboldened the FCC, who gave out bigger and bigger fines. By 2006, Congress passed a law instructing the FCC to issue fines of $325,000 for broadcasting swear words on Radio and TV. With all of that going on, the bleep sensor became more and more popular. People wanted edgier content,
而且，FCC确实有权决定什么适合电波，什么不适合。这一裁决助长了FCC的气焰，他们开出的罚单越来越大。到2006年，国会通过了一项法律，指示FCC对在广播和电视上播出脏话的行为处以32.5万美元的罚款。在这一切背景下，“哔”音传感器变得越来越受欢迎。人们想要更大胆的内容，
stuff that felt more like real life, and at the same time, the FCC was going fine-crazy. So, the bleep was a perfect solution. In part, because the bleep doesn't just erase a bad word, it also draws attention to it. The bleep, I think, is good in so far as it announces. We are messing with what it is that we're showing you. Robert Thompson is a professor of media history at Syracuse University.
那些感觉更贴近现实生活的东西，与此同时，FCC却在疯狂开罚单。因此，“哔”音成了完美的解决方案。部分原因在于，“哔”音不仅抹去了脏话，它还把注意力吸引到了脏话上。我认为，“哔”音的好处在于它宣告了：我们在干预我们向你展示的内容。罗伯特·汤普森（Robert Thompson）是雪城大学的媒体历史教授。
What you are about to see is not happening the way it actually happened. It's been changed and we've got this obvious beep that warns you of that. And bleeps throughout our life are generally warnings. If a garbage truck is backing up toward you, you hear the bleeps to warn you before a weather advisory comes up on your television set. We hear those annoying beeps. The bleep sound became popular in part because it is obnoxious. It feels kind of elicit, even while it is technically covering up the swear word.
你即将看到的内容并不是以它实际发生的方式呈现的。它已经被修改了，我们用这个明显的“哔”音来向你发出警告。我们生活中的“哔”音通常都是警告。如果有一辆垃圾车在倒车向你靠近，你会听到“哔”声来警告你，或者在你的电视机上出现天气预警之前。我们会听到那些恼人的蜂鸣声。“哔”音之所以流行，部分原因在于它很讨厌。它带有一种违禁的感觉，尽管它技术上是在掩盖脏话。
The bleep, in my opinion, actually emphasizes it underlines, it foregrounds it. By the early 2000s, the bleep was everywhere. The Jerry Springer show made it a mainstay of daytime TV, while reality shows like The Bachelor made it a staple in prime time. And TV sensors became more Lucy Goosey in how they use the bleep. If you listen to a bleep, a smart bleeper can often get the bleep begin after the first consonant of the word and end before the last consonant of the word. Everybody knows what they're saying. Lip reading will usually do it in itself. The advocacy group, the parents television and media counsel, did a study in the early 2000s and found that bleeping increased by, please don't laugh, 69% during a five-year period.
在我看来，“哔”音实际上是在强调它、下划线标注它、将其置于前台。到21世纪初，“哔”音无处不在。杰瑞·斯普林格秀（The Jerry Springer Show）将其变成了日间电视节目的顶梁柱，而像《单身汉》这样的真人秀则将其变成了黄金时段的常青树。电视审查员在使用“哔”音时也变得更加随心所欲。如果你仔细听一个“哔”音，“哔”得巧妙的人通常可以让“哔”音在单词的第一个辅音之后开始，并在单词的最后一个辅音之前结束。大家都知道他们在说什么。看唇语通常就能心领神会。家长电视和媒体委员会（Parents Television and Media Council）这个倡导组织在21世纪初做了一项研究，发现在五年期间，“哔”音的使用量增加了——请不要笑——69%。
Reality TV was a big driver of this increase in bleeps, but there's another reason it really took off in the early 2000s. It's the rise of what Maria Bustio's calls the comedic meta-bleep. The moments when a comedy show uses the bleep not to cover up a swear word, but as a punchline in and of itself. It's like the strange signal for every viewer of like, we're going to break into your effective dream now and introduce the concept of notiness or indecency. A bleep is like a rimshot after a joke. If you didn't hear that bad word, we bleeped it so you could
真人秀节目是“哔”音激增的主要推手，但21世纪初它真正腾飞还有另一个原因。这就是玛丽亚·布斯蒂略斯所称的“喜剧元哔音”（comedic meta-bleep）的兴起。也就是喜剧节目使用“哔”音不是为了掩盖脏话，而是将其本身作为一个笑点的时刻。这就像是对所有观众发出的一种奇怪的信号，仿佛在说：我们要闯入你当下的梦境，引入淘气或不雅的概念。“哔”音就像是一个笑话讲完后的军鼓重击（rimshot）。如果你没听到那个脏话，我们把它“哔”掉了，好让你
be sure that you knew where it was. The idea of the comedy bleep is actually pretty old. Comedian Jack Parr did a version of the joke in the 1960s, replacing words in famous advertisements with a cuckoo clock sound. Mother, please, I'd rather... myself. What's wrong, Helen? Maybe it's your... The toothpaste for people who can't always be between meals.
确信你知道它在哪里。喜剧“哔”音的想法其实相当古老。喜剧演员杰克·帕尔（Jack Paar）在20世纪60年代就做过这个笑话的一个版本，他用布谷鸟钟的声音替换了著名广告中的词汇。妈妈，求你了，我宁愿……我自己。怎么了，海伦？也许是你的……这是给那些不能总在两餐之间……的人准备的牙膏。
In the early 2000s, it became a standard type of joke, where the bleep button is used so much, it sounds absurd. My favorite example of this was the Osborne starting in 2002. Way funnier to watch that show as it aired with the bleeps than to play it on DVD or finding it on streaming without the bleeps. The bleeps had almost a morse code telegraphic kind of rhythm and music to it.
在21世纪初，这成了一种标准的笑话类型，其中“哔”音按钮被用得如此频繁，听起来极其荒谬。我最喜欢的例子是2002年开播的《奥斯朋一家》（The Osbournes）。看那档节目时带着“哔”音直播，比在DVD上播放或在流媒体上找无“哔”音版要搞笑得多。这些“哔”音几乎有一种摩斯密码电报般的节奏和音乐感。
I'm a second tired of **** profanity as poetry courtesy of of the bleep. Everywhere I go this is driving me mandal. One of my favorite ones was the
我一秒钟也受够了……通过“哔”音呈现的粗俗诗意。我走到哪里，这都快把我逼疯了。我最喜欢的一个片段是
writers of a arrested development. There's an arrested development episode where they're bleeping all the way through the scene and nobody can tell exactly what they were saying. You know I'm in pretty good shape. You could be my dust all day, slowpoke. And you might be eating.
《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）的编剧。《发展受阻》里有一集，他们在整个场景中一直在“哔”音，没有人能准确分辨他们在说什么。你知道我状态挺好的。你一整天都可以吃我的灰，慢吞吞的家伙。而你可能在吃。
That's gonna. Well, let's hope it doesn't come to that. The show's creator, Mitch Herwitz, says his actors weren't actually swearing during these sequences. They would say the words, lip flap. So if somebody read their lips, they wouldn't be able to tell what swear word it was supposed to be. Herwitz explained the jokes appeal to MPR.
那会。好吧，希望事情不会发展到那一步。该剧的创作者米奇·赫维茨（Mitch Herwitz）表示，他的演员在这些片段中实际上并没有说脏话。他们会说出这些词，但只有唇形。所以如果有人读他们的唇语，也无法分辨出它本来应该是哪个脏话。赫维茨向美国国家公共电台（NPR）解释了这种笑话的吸引力。
That was the point at which we realized, you know, it's more fun to not know exactly what it is that we're saying. It becomes kind of a puzzle for people. And I think it's about, you know, letting your imagination do the work. The apotheosis of this trend is a recurring sketch on Jimmy Kimmel's late night show. It's called Unnecessary Centorship,
那就是我们意识到的时候，你知道，不知道我们到底在说什么其实更有趣。这成了人们的一种谜题。我认为这关乎于，你知道，让你的想象力发挥作用。这种趋势的巅峰是吉米·坎摩尔（Jimmy Kimmel）深夜秀上的一个重复小品。它被称为“不必要的审查”（Unnecessary Censorship），
where he replaces parts of perfectly normal sentences with long obnoxious weaves. President Obama delivered his final state of the Union address and urged Americans to build a quote, big-****** nation. We've got this space program almost overnight and 12 years later, we're ****ing on the moon. In so many ways, the sensor bleep noise
在那里，他把完全正常的句子的一部分替换成了长而讨厌的“哔”声。奥巴马总统发表了最后的国情咨文，敦促美国人建设一个引述为“宏大且******的国家”。我们几乎在一夜之间建立起了这个太空计划，12年后，我们在月球上“哔——”。在很多方面，传感器发出的“哔”音
is like a super swear. It can be used to barely conceal a swear word like on Jerry Springer, or it can be used to let our minds run wild and consider all sorts of possibilities like arrested development. As a tool of censorship, it's not that effective, which is why certain political action groups would like to see it dead. Hello, Tim. Can you hear me, Chris?
就像是一个超级脏话。它可以用来勉强掩盖脏话，比如在《杰瑞·斯普林格秀》中，或者它可以用来任由我们的思绪狂野奔跑，思考各种可能性，就像在《发展受阻》中一样。作为一种审查工具，它并不是那么有效，这就是为什么某些政治行动集团希望看到它彻底消亡。哈喽，蒂姆。你能听到我说话吗，克里斯？
Tim Winter is the head of the parents' television and media council. We are a grassroots nonprofit, nonpartisan organization. Our mission is to protect children from the graphic sex violence and profanity that seems so pervasive on our entertainment media today. The PTC is famous for having monitors watch broadcast TV and submit complaints to the Federal Communications Commission. They also do things like lobbying Congress
蒂姆·温特（Tim Winter）是家长电视和媒体委员会的负责人。我们是一个基层非营利、无党派组织。我们的使命是保护儿童免受当今娱乐媒体中无处不在的血腥、暴力和亵渎语言的侵害。PTC因安排监督员观看广播电视并向联邦通信委员会提交投诉而闻名。他们还做诸如游说国会的事情，
to increase the fines against broadcasters who put swearing on the air. The PTC believes TV and radio should be a family-friendly haven where content is appropriate for everyone. And for Tim, that conviction has created a complicated relationship with believing. First and foremost, when it comes to a bleep button versus hearing the profanity, especially on entertainment content that is likely to be consumed by children, the bleep button is better than the profanity, usually, generally speaking, in our opinion.
以加大对在广播中播出脏话的广播公司的罚款力度。PTC认为电视和广播应该是一个适合家庭的避风港，其中的内容对每个人来说都是合适的。对蒂姆来说，这种信念与“哔”音产生了一种复杂的关系。首先也是最重要的，当涉及到“哔”音按钮与听到亵渎语言相比时，特别是在可能被儿童消费的娱乐内容上，在我们看来，通常、一般来说，“哔”音按钮比亵渎语言更好。
is better than the propanity, usually, generally speaking, in our opinion. It's one of those things where we don't want to let perfect be the enemy of good. But still, he thinks the bleep button isn't some neutral thing. In Tim's mind, the bleep button is kind of like cheating. If the intention is to shock, then he put the loud bleep in there. And that's exactly what they're doing. They're doing it for effect. This is no earnest effort to make sure that the program it doesn't violate in decent standards.
比亵渎语言更好，通常、一般来说，在我们看来。这属于那种我们不想让完美成为优秀的敌人的情况。不过，他依然认为“哔”音按钮并非什么中立的事物。在蒂姆看来，按下“哔”音按钮有点像作弊。如果其意图是为了震惊，那么他们就把响亮的“哔”音放在那里。这正是他们在做的事。他们是为了效果而这么做的。这绝不是为了确保节目不违反不雅标准的真诚努力。
This is a way to almost do the opposite. You're doing it intentionally to suggest and to provoke. You're almost adding it back in and adding emphasis to it, even though you're not saying the words. In 2010, the PTC launched a boycott against a sitcom based on a Twitter account called SH***** My Dad Says. The Twitter thread used a profanity in the title, but the show didn't, and in the trailers, they actually just used the word bleep. word, bleep. Bleep, my dad says.
这几乎是一种反其道而行之的方式。你这么做是故意暗示和挑衅。你几乎是把它重新加了进去，并对其进行了强调，尽管你没有说出那些词。2010年，PTC针对一部根据推特账号“SH***** My Dad Says”改编的情景喜剧发起了抵制。该推特话题在标题中使用了一句脏话，但节目没有，而在预告片中，他们实际上只用了“哔”这个词。词，哔。我老爸说，哔。
Thursday's this fall, only CBS. They called sponsors of Bleep, my dad says, and told them to boycott the show. It was canceled after a few episodes, mostly because nobody was really watching. The bleep button might be on its way out, but not for the Protect the Children Reasons favored by Tim Winter and the PTC. It's because swearing across society has become more and more accepted. A Reuters poll found that only 14% of Americans never swear in day-to-day life. Recently, the FCC has lost some of its regulatory power.
今年秋天周四，仅在CBS播出。他们打电话给《我老爸说，哔》的赞助商，告诉他们抵制这部剧。播出几集后它就被取消了，主要是因为根本没人看。“哔”音按钮可能正在走向淘汰，但原因并不是蒂姆·温特和PTC所推崇的“保护儿童”的理由。这是因为整个社会对脏话变得越来越习以为常。路透社的一项民意调查发现，只有14%的美国人在日常生活中从不说脏话。最近，FCC失去了一些监管权力。
In 2010, the second circuit court of appeals struck down the FCC's right to levy fines for fleeting swear words in live broadcast, saying their rules were, quote, unconstitutionally vague. In the years since that ruling TV and radio hasn't been a vulgarity free-for-all, advertisers and parents probably wouldn't abide that, but the standards are definitely changing. Most stations don't bleep words like bitch or ass anymore. It's possible we're heading towards a world where and won't be beeped out, but personally I hope we keep the bleep. The bleep button is America's super ego. It's the desire to say exactly what we want
2010年，第二巡回上诉法院推翻了FCC对直播中稍纵即逝的脏话征收罚款的权利，称其规则“违宪且含糊不清”。在该裁决之后的几年里，电视和广播并没有变成粗俗的自由地带，广告商和家长可能不会容忍这一点，但标准绝对在改变。大多数电台不再对“婊子”（bitch）或“混蛋”（ass）之类的词进行消音了。我们很有可能会走向一个……和……不会被“哔”掉的世界，但就我个人而言，我希望我们能保留“哔”音。“哔”音按钮是美国的超我。它是我们想要畅所欲言、随时随地说出我们想说的话的欲望，以及我们知道自己做不到的认知。稍后回来，我们探讨在直播期间审查脏话的精细艺术。我已经准备好按下那个巨大的红色按钮了，因为在这个时候，我觉得，这要是播出了，电台会被罚款，我的整个职业生涯就全完了。稍后继续收听克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Berube）的节目。
all the time and the knowledge that we can't. When we come back, the delicate art of centering swear words during live broadcasts. I'm ready to press the big red button, because at this point, I'm like, off this goes over the air, stations can get fined, my whole career is over. More with Chris Baroube, after this.
今天，当你在广播和电视上听到“哔”音按钮时，它几乎总是出现在预科内容中，比如真人秀节目或情景喜剧。但它很少用于直播。想想看，所有那些你看到直播出现严重差错的时刻。比如威尔·史密斯（Will Smith）在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上扇了克里斯·洛克（Chris Rock）耳光，然后他开始大喊大叫，导播直接切断了他的声音。每当职业运动员情绪失控时也是如此。静音作为电视上对脏话的替代品效果很好，因为
Today, when you hear the Bleep button on Radio and TV, it's almost always in pre-recorded content, like a reality TV show or a sitcom. But it's rarely used in live broadcast. Think about all the times you've seen something go horribly wrong on live TV. Like when Will Smith slapped Chris Rock at the Oscars, then he started yelling, and they just cut off his sound. Same thing anytime a professional athlete loses their cool. Silence works just fine as a replacement for a bad word on television, because there
仍然有图像在广播。但在广播电台，静音可不管用。人们认为静音就是死寂（dead air）。多年来，直播广播一直使用“哔”音特效，但他们在20世纪70年代停用了。这是因为有一个控台操作员非常不喜欢“哔”音按钮。大多数时候你根本不需要“哔”音，话说回来，你之所以叫它“哔”音，只是因为你得给它起个名字。它其实只是一种用来填补那段空白的音调，
are still images being broadcast. But on the radio, silence doesn't cut it. People think silence is dead air. For years, live radio used the bleep sound effect, but they stopped in the 1970s. And that's because of one board operator who really did not like the bleep button. Most of the time you didn't need the bleep, which again, you're calling it a bleep only because you got to call it something. It's really just a tone to fill that air
同时把那些淘气的内容抹去。那是理查德·法克特。你刚才听过他的声音了，他在20世纪60年代是W-A-B-C电台的控台操作员。但在那之后的几年里，理查德和几个朋友开了一家名为“潮起潮落”（Event Tide）的新音频公司，该公司在音频界轰动一时。
while the naughtyness went away. That's Richard Factor. You heard from him earlier, he was a board operator at W-A-B-C in the 1960s. But a few years after that, Richard started a new audio company with some friends called Even Tide, which became a huge deal in the audio world.
他们为音频工程师创造了各种各样的效果，其中一些曾被大卫·鲍伊（David Bowie）和埃迪·范·海伦（Eddie Van Halen）使用过。但他们在1977年的一项发明永远改变了广播。它被称为广播音频延迟。我常常很难向普通人类解释清楚，当别人问“理查德，你是做什么的？”我说，嗯，
They created all kinds of effects for audio engineers, some of which were used by David Bowie and Eddie Van Halen. But one of their inventions, in 1977, changed radio forever. It was called the Broadcast Audio Delay. I have a lot of trouble just talking to standard humans, saying, Richard, what do you do? And I said, well,
我是一个发明家。哦，你有什么专利吗？有啊，你的专利是什么？是那个让脏话不上广播的东西。基本上，理查德的广播延迟器允许控台操作员在不使用“哔”音按钮的情况下剪掉脏话。它是这样运作的。记住，大多数直播广播都有七秒钟的磁带延迟，这意味着直播实际上比它们在现实生活中发生的时间滞后七秒钟播出。理查德的发明——广播延迟器，让这一点更进一步。
I'm an inventor. Oh, do you have any patents? Yes, what's your patent on? The thing that keeps the naughty words off the radio. Basically, Richard's broadcast delay allows a board operator to cut out a swear word without using the bleep button. Here's how it works. Remember, most live radio broadcasts run on a seven-second tape delay, meaning live broadcasts actually get transmitted seven seconds later than they happen in real life. Richard's invention, the broadcast delay, took it a step further.
这台机器有一个黑色的面板，中间有一个巨大的黄色按钮，上面写着“转储”（dump）这个词。如果有人说脏话，控台操作员可以按下“转储”按钮，直接从延迟广播切到实时直播，本质上就是跳过了脏话。为什么要叫“转储”？为什么“转储”这个词看起来是这个特定功能的合适名称？嗯，因为这正是你正在做的事情。你把一些词汇转储到无限远或虚无之中，随你怎么挑。你给了我一个机会，
The machine has a black panel with a giant yellow button in the middle with the word dump on it. If somebody squares, the board operator can hit the dump button and cut straight from the tape-delayed broadcast to the live feed, essentially skipping over the square. Why dump? Why did the word dump seem like the right name for that particular function? Well, because that's precisely what you're doing. You're taking some words and dumping them into infinity or nowhere, take your pick. And you've given me the opportunity to,
我想他们称之为致敬（props），向我的好朋友肯尼·谢弗（Kenny Schaeffer）致敬，他经常抱怨自己没有因为这些事情得到足够的认可，但他才是发明“转储”按钮的人。如果你转储得当，脏话就会凭空消失，而且神不知鬼不觉。我们想听听“转储”按钮的实际效果，于是我们打电话给杰克·格兰茨（Jake Glanz），
I think they call them props, give props to my buddy Kenny Schaeffer, who is often complains that he doesn't get enough credit for stuff, but he's the one who invented the dump button. If you dump correctly, the bad word just disappears and no one's the wiser. We wanted to hear the dump button in action, so we called up Jake Glanz,
他是SiriusXM（天狼星XM）的广播工程主管。这家公司——嘿，你瞧——拥有《无形之物》的版权。喂，你在直播。嗨，我是克里斯·鲁贝，你的同事。这是杰克吗？这是你的电台号码无形之物。喂，你在直播。嗨，我是菲斯·里贝奇，你知道的，杰克。这是你的号码一。喂。
the head of broadcast engineering at SiriusXM. A company that, hey, look at that, owns 99% invisible. Hi, you're on the air. Hi, it's Ciprube, colleague. Is this Jake? This is your color number invisible. Hi, you're on the air. Hi, it's fifth rebech, all you know, Jake. This is your color number one. Hi.
这是你第一次在广播里以受访者的身份做这件事吗？不，也许你没意识到你正在和“杰克的早安烘焙”（Jake's Waken Bake）的前主持人说话。在涉足大学广播明星之路后，杰克花了多年时间担任控台操作员。
Is this your first time doing this on the air as an honor person? No, perhaps you didn't realize you're talking to the former host of Jake's Waken Bake. After his foray into college radio stardom, Jake spent years working as a board operator.
他说，按下“转储”按钮是让控台操作员夜不能寐的事情。这让人压力山大，特别是如果你试图操控一个非常复杂的节目，要处理与时间的赛跑中遇到的直播连线，你可能还有一些必须死守的硬性时间节点。这太让人崩溃了。让我们做一个“转储”按钮的实操演示。在这个练习中，我要打进一个直播电台节目。我们假设“糖果”（Gumdrop）是你听过的最糟糕的脏话。
And he says hitting the dump button is the thing that keeps Boredops awake at night. It's overwhelming because especially if you're trying to engineer a very complicated show dealing with live collars working against a clock that you have some hard times perhaps you have to hit. It's overwhelming. Let's do a demonstration of the dump button in action. For this exercise, I'm going to call into a live radio show. And let's pretend Gumdrop is the worst swear word you've ever heard.
记住这一点。糖果。好的，我们开始吧。准备好了吗？你觉得准备好了吗？当然。这里是KNPI，全建筑电台，随时随地。我们从美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心为您进行现场直播，
Keep it in mind. Gumdrop. OK, so here we go. Are we ready? Do you feel ready? Sure. This is KNPI, all architecture all the time. We're coming to you live from beautiful uptown,
阳光明媚，气温73华氏度。今天，我们在讨论勒·柯布西耶（Le Corbusier），他是被误解的天才还是被高估的庸才？我们有来自多伦多的克里斯在线。你在直播。谢谢邀请，我是一名老听众了。所以，勒·柯布西耶，别拿这家伙开玩笑了。他说建筑是居住的机器，我的意思是，拜托，我才不想住在一台机器里，那个笨蛋以为人们会住在这些愚蠢的糖果建筑里，周围没有任何糖果
Oakland, California, with sunny and 73 degrees. Today, we're talking look or busier, misunderstood genius or overrated hack. We've got Chris from Toronto online. You're on the air. Thanks for having the first time, long time. So look or busier, get out of here with this guy. He said that buildings are machines for living it, which I mean, come on, I don't want to live in a machine that moron thought people would live in these stupid gum drop buildings with no gum drop
便利设施。或者你看到一件衬衫就贴在他擅长的地方。所以，当我在那里狂吼大叫时，像杰克这样的控台操作员就会按下那个巨大的黄色“转储”按钮。而这才是听众在收音机里会听到的声音。他说建筑是居住的机器，我的意思是，拜托，我才不想住在一台机器里。那个笨蛋以为人们会住在这些非常激情的建筑里。好的，谢谢你，克里斯。下一位来电者。好的。我想我们成功了。
amenities anywhere close by. Or do you see a shirt just stuck to where he's good at. So while I'm ranting and raving, a birdop like Jake would hit the big yellow dump button. And this is what folks would hear on the radio. He said that buildings are machines for living it, which I mean, come on, I don't want to live in a machine. That moron thought people would live in these very passionate. Okay, thank you, Chris. Next caller. Okay. I think we got it.
没错。希望这个效果不会鼓励人们去考验控台操作员及时反应的能力。请不要打电话来用你的本地控台操作员做这种测试。我曾经是个控台操作员。那真的，很没礼貌。现在，你可能已经注意到了“转储”按钮的一个问题。在你消除了那七秒钟的延迟之后，如果稍后节目中有人再次说脏话，你就有点完蛋了。所以理查德·法克特的
Yep. Let's hope that the effect of this is not going to encourage people to test the, uh, the board ops, uh, ability to react in time. Please do not call in to test this with your local board operator. I used to be a board operator. That's just, and consider it. Now, you might have noticed an issue with the dump button. After you eliminate the seven seconds delay, you're kind of screwed if somebody swears again later in the program. So Richard Factor's
广播延迟器包含了一项第二创新，即时间拉伸软件，它会在接下来的几分钟内慢慢重建磁带延迟。基本上，该软件会寻找语音中的微小停顿，然后将它们拉脱长。如果是谈话节目形式，你可以在停顿之间增加延迟并利用这一点。因此，自然的语速会被拉长，我想，延迟会在词与词之间的沉默时段建立起来。你可以在几分钟内建立起一定数量的安全延迟时间。如果你听直播广播，你很有可能听到过“转储”按钮起作用，而且你很可能没有注意到它。“转储”按钮的吸引力显而易见。它抹去了脏话，
broadcast delay included a second innovation, time stretching software that would slowly rebuild the tape delay over the next few minutes. Basically, the software looks for little pauses in speech and then stretches them out. If it was a talk show format, you could kind of add the delay between pauses and take advantage of that. So the natural speech would kind of be elongated, I guess, the delays would be built when there was silence between the words. You could build up, say, within a couple minutes to get to a safe amount of delay time. If you listen to live radio, there's a good chance you've heard the dump button in action, and there's a good chance you didn't notice it. The appeal of the dump button is obvious. It wipes out the square word,
并且让人觉得什么都没发生过。理查德·法克特说，在大多数情况下，广播电台更喜欢“转储”按钮，而不是那种侵入性的、令人讨厌的“哔”音。嗯，当然，就节目编排而言，天衣无缝肯定是更好的。毫无疑问，当你在播放一个节目而没有人能看出出了什么问题时，你就会过得更好。
and makes it seem like nothing happened. Richard Factor says, for the most part, radio stations prefer the dump button to that intrusive obnoxious bleep. Well, for sure, in terms of programming, it's better if it's seamless. I have no doubt at all that when you run a program and nobody can tell something's gone wrong, you're better off.
但这种天衣无缝的过渡对听众来说更好吗？文化作家玛丽亚·布斯蒂略斯认为，静音剥夺了重要的上下文。她说“哔”音实际上更好。我认为“哔”音实际上比任何其他形式的审查都更能揭示真相，对听众或观众也更好。比如我们现在潜在的做法是，他们可以抹去你不能无缝抹去或移除的东西。就像你根本不会知道那里曾有一个空白（lacuna）。
But is this seamless transition better for listeners? Maria Bustillo, the culture writer, she thinks that silence is taking away important context. And she says the bleep sound is actually better. I think that the bleep is actually more revealing and better for listeners or viewers than any other form of censorship. Like what we have now potentially is they can erase the thing that you're not seamlessly erase or remove. Like you won't know that there was a lacuna at all.
我认为这真的很具破坏性。我们都知道媒体有多么操纵人心。而观众或听众可能会对所做出的任何修改完全蒙在鼓里，你知道的。我认为“哔”音更健康。让我们回想一下杰克·格兰茨职业生涯早期的一起事件。杰克18岁时，在开始做“早安烘焙”之前，他在新英格兰的一家黑人电台担任一档政治节目的控台操作员。
And I think that's really harmful. We all know how manipulative media can be. And the viewer listener may remain completely naive to that, you know, whatever alterations have been made. I think a bleep is healthier. Let's consider an incident from early in Jake Clanz's career. When Jake was 18 before he was waking and baking, he was working as a board operator for a politics show on a black owned radio station in New England.
一天下午，节目正在主持一场竞选公职的两位候选人之间的辩论。一位黑人候选人正在与一位白人现任官员竞选，杰克说现任官员对当时的局势很不高兴。现任官员。杰克说，现任官员对当时的局势很不高兴。现任官员在某个时刻情绪失控了。我不确定那是不是N开头的那个词（指黑鬼）。无论他说的是什么，杰克记得那是一个污蔑性的词。于是杰克开始恐慌。我面前就有一个延迟器。我准备好按下那个巨大的红色按钮了，我打算按下它，因为在这个时候
One afternoon, the show was hosting a debate between two candidates running for office. A black candidate was running against a white incumbent and Jake says the incumbent was not thrilled with the situation. incumbent. And Jake says, the incumbent was not thrilled with the situation. The incumbent loses his cool at one point. And I'm not sure if it was the end word. Whatever he said, Jake remembers it being a slur. And so Jake started to panic. I have a delay right in front of me. And I'm ready to oppress the big red button. And I go to press it because at this point
我觉得这要是播出了，电台会被罚款，他们会，你知道的，开除我，我的整个职业生涯就全完了。所以，在这种情况下，正确的做法是什么？如果攻击性的词汇播出了，杰克和电台可能会惹上FCC的麻烦。如果杰克使用“哔”音按钮，也许这会淡化一个非常严肃的情况，因为“哔”音按钮有点搞笑。但如果杰克做一个无缝剪辑，把整段话都抹去了，那么听众可能会
I'm like off this goes over the air, stations can get fine, they're gonna, you know, excommunicate me my whole career is over. So in a situation like this, what's the right move? If the offensive word goes out on the air, Jake and the station could get in trouble with the FCC. If Jake uses the bleep button, maybe that trivializes a really serious situation because the bleep button is kind of funny. But if Jake does a seamless cut and just eliminates the whole thing, then the listener could be
错过关于竞选人的真正具有揭露性的信息。显然，这些都不是完美的解决方案。好吧，实际情况是这样的。杰克的电台台长就站在他旁边。当现任官员开始狂怒时，台长告诉杰克让这个污蔑性的词汇播出去。对于这个故事，重要的是要知道杰克的台长是个黑人。总经理按住我的手不让我按按钮。
missing out on really telling information about somebody running for office. Clearly, none of these are perfect solutions. Okay, here's what actually happened. Jake's station manager was standing right beside him. And when the incumbent started ranting, the manager told Jake to let the slur go out on the radio. For this story, it's important to know that Jake's manager was black. The general manager held my hand from pressing the button.
他说，这是个新闻节目。我们没事的。我对此不太确定，但我还是说，好吧。事实证明，杰克并没有惹上麻烦。电台没有被罚款。事实上，杰克认为这一刻对选举产生了积极的影响。
And he goes, this is a news program. We're okay. I'm not so sure about that, but I was like, okay. It turns out Jake didn't get in trouble. The station wasn't fine. In fact, Jake thinks this moment impacted the election in a positive way.
瞧，那位现任官员输掉了竞选。是的，可以说是他的真面目暴露了。说到审查制度，正确的选择并不总是显而易见的。如果在“哔”音、无缝剪辑或保留脏话之间做选择，我其实不知道我更倾向于哪一个。这三种都有很好的论据。对我来说，整件事感觉就像是一个巨大的f***ing悖论。由克里斯·鲁贝制作的《无形之物》由凯利·普罗恩（Kelly Prone）编辑，原创音乐由斯旺西（Swansea）提供。这段1912年约翰·施特劳斯（Johann Strauss）的《蓝色多瑙河圆舞曲》录音由
Loan behold that incumbent lost the race. Yeah, his true colors came out, so to speak. When it comes to censorship, the right choice isn't always obvious. If it's a call between a bleep sound or a seamless cut or including a swear word, I actually don't know what I prefer. There are good arguments for all three. For me, the whole thing just feels like a big f***ing paradox. 99% of us vote with produces weak by Chrisoube, edited by Kelly Prone, original music by Swansea. This 1912 recording of Johann Strauss's Blue Danube Waltz courtesy
国会图书馆提供，混音和额外制作由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzales）负责，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）负责。我们的执行制片人是莱尼·霍尔（Leni Hall），柯特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）是我们的数字总监。团队成员包括维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、杰森·迪利恩（Jason Dillion）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、拉沙·马顿（Lashamadon）、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonana Medina）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、索菲娅·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马尔斯。本周特别感谢本·弗里施（Ben Frisch）、米娅·伯恩（Mia Bern）、贾里德·奥康奈尔（Jared O'Connell）和玛丽亚·布斯蒂略斯，她在科技网站The Verge上关于“哔”音的文章启发了这期节目。你可以在《Popular》和《Break House cooperative》找到玛丽亚的更多作品。
of the Library of Congress, sound mix and additional production by Martin Gonzales, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Our executive producer is Leni Hall, Kurt Colstad, is our digital director. The rise of team includes Vivian Le, Jason Dillion, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Lashamadon, Jacob Maldonana Medina, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Ben Frisch, Mia Bern, Jared O'Connell, and Maria Bustios, who's article about the bleep for the text site The Verge helped inspire this episode. You can find more of Maria's work at Popular and the Break House cooperative.
我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦（Pandora building）。位于美丽、繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上@罗曼·马尔斯，或@99 PI Orc。我们在Instagram上也有账号，准备好了。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜爱的其他电台节目的链接，
We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99 PI Orc. We're on Instagram and ready to. You can find links to others to church shows I love,
以及《无形之物》过去的每一期节目。你正在收听来自 SiriusXM 旗下的 Stitcher 播客。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。
as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI. .org. You're listening to a s***er podcast from s***zXM. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及 99PI 的所有往期节目，网址是 99PI.org。您正在收听来自 SiriusXM 的优质播客。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。